she come
men take your
feet shoulder width apart
ladies
in width apart
so start with the
start with the feet together
choose the foot it doesn't matter
take them hit with the part then
shoulder width apart
if you hang your arms down
you'll be able to gauge
how wide your shoulders are it's not so
important
what's important is just
getting your feet used to
the floor
[Music]
i'm gonna slowly push one
down as i shift my weight over and lift
the other one up
slowly push it down
lift the other one up
[Music]
this leg is straight this one is
slightly soft
as it pushes down and transfers away
it becomes straight this one becomes
slightly bent
and soft
straight soft
bend
[Music]
and building it up but not too
fast
i'm doing this for the camera
it would take a lot longer i'd perhaps
do this
for a few minutes
there's no rush no competition
next exercise
start with the feet if the feet are
comfortable
you give them good exercise sensitivity
comes
you're heightened awareness through your
feet
we need to let gouchy come flowing from
our body
rising manifesting itself into
this wonderful feeling not just power
but this wonderful feeling of energy
building okay so
my hands
don't have your arms and your elbows too
close to you
[Music]
but first i go around like this
around around
and then we're going to change the
angle to
flat circles
flat circles work the hands first so you
know what you're doing
and then start shifting the white
on the feet
try to feel the circles
running all the way through your feet so
your body
starts to go in the circles of your arms
then you feel like you're throwing out
gathering in throwing out
gathering in
change direction
do everything in both directions
so you can start with the arms
try not to bring them in don't let them
don't don't let them collapse inwards
they collapse inwards you
lose your power if you were doing push
hands
they would push their power into you
because you've
let your energy come in you need to push
your energy out so
yeah the first one
circles
you can move your body up on your toes
if you wish
anything to make your toes alive
with the feeling of your arms then just
the arms
make circles remember
not to come in not to come in
then allow the body to start
floating with it this is
the hips now now i need the feet to be
moving
i need the feet to be moving
so that the feet feel like they're going
round
covering all the foot the edge of the
foot the heel
[Music]
arms first
and the hips
and the feet
[Music]
but you don't have to have a set number
i like to go with some people say
21 times you know 10 times
10 9 times try to feel
try to feel what's right for you
if you enjoy doing it
keep doing it
okay by now
if you're doing it with me you should
start to feel your hands
becoming warm or tingle
and alive
alive
alive so rocking now
rocking now as with the first one
but the hands now are facing each other
so now the right hand
will push the energy to the left
and the left will push the energy to the
right
but you don't see it like this
but that's what you're doing inside your
push okay but it looks more like you're
floating
and your senses your senses
the sensory perception is
[Music]
inhale exhale
inhale
exhale take a breath
exhale by swapping over
inhale exhale
inhale
[Music]
arms still away from the body
the hands should be alive and
lots of energy now in your fingers
try as you make the circles
[Music]
the legs are becoming very strong now
making the circles and just
making a circle with your body
there's no way of doing it wrong
touch these two fingers
onto there so when you're finishing
bring them around
touch your two fingers and your legs
bring one in
close
stand tall and calm
relax shoulders
[Music]
thank you for your time